this week on quad Riga Pope Francis a
year of change on March 13 2013
Argentine Cardinal Jorge Mario bergoglio
was elected the new head of the Catholic
Church the first Latin American Pope
athelia sur la buona sera Pope Francis
quickly became a symbol of hope that the
Vatican was undergoing a fundamental
change the popular likeable pontiff is
seen as representing simplicity and
humility rejecting the luxuries of the
church and reaching out to the public
but will the catholic church as a whole
be able to follow his lead or is it too
mired in tradition your host this week
Melinda crane hello and welcome to
quadriga the Pope's first year
anniversary has prompted a wealth of
commentary but a perhaps surprising lack
of agreement has he really initiated a
process of revolutionary change and
Kenny and future live up to the
expectations that this first year has
raised that's what we want to talk about
today with three Vatican watchers it's
my pleasure to introduce Derek's Scully
he's the Berlin correspondent of the
irish times he covers German and
European politics and cultural affairs
and he reported closely on Pope Benedict
Martin gac is originally from Argentina
has a PhD in philosophy and regularly
writes on religion and ethics for a
variety of media including his own blog
the radical secularist
and Claudia color is an editor at the
german-based paper de tagesspiegel where
religious affairs is among the areas
which she covers the Pope has attracted
almost 7 million visitors to papal
events since he has been in office he
recently found himself compelled to
remind people that he's not a superstar
what accounts for this absolutely
astonishing popularity mounting Jack I
think that there is an astonishing
contrast between this Pope and whatever
we saw for the last say 2000 years so
the history that we hear about the
church and I think that what we see
coming into the 9 light I mean we can
make probably some exceptions virgin
Paul the second but the contrast between
what the Vatican was a year ago and the
way we thought about the Vatican a year
ago and what we think about the vatican
today I think accounts for the not only
the contrast but sort of the the
relevance of the figure the question is
Claudia Koerner will it really amount to
a true revitalization of the Catholic
Church surveys seem to show that
Catholics for instance here in Germany
or in the u.s. they're enthusiastic
about Pope Francis but they're not
necessarily going to church any more
often well being answered enthusiastic
is the first step I guess and I think he
has already revitalized the church and
here not only his own people but also
secular people acs like people are
fascinated by him and a willing to
listen to him and i think this is the
first step what do you think Derek
Scully is there really anything more to
this than a shift in papal style so to
speak a kind of a rebranding of this
ancient institution well I think if you
were to talk to some Mad Men some
advertising executives who'd say if you
want to change the content you have to
change the perceptions first and that's
I think what we've seen I mean he's
obviously been thinking about this
himself but yeah you could also hire in
some very expensive advertising
executives who would give you the same
advice change the perception of the
brand if the brand is considered a
problem and only then can you actually
go in and look at the
the content of the product itself and I
think that's what we've seen in the last
year and yeah we are now into the next
phase which is going inside well has
been a very problematic brand for the
last couple of years Martin duck a
report mentioned his simplicity his
humility are those the kind of
attributes that are attracting so much
enthusiasm and fervor or is it actually
a hope for true doctrinal change that's
that's that's making people so so
interested I think that we are not
seeing a change in doctrinal content I
think that what we're seeing is a change
in doctrinal emphasis that is to say we
have moved from questions of say the
prevalence of sexual morality as a
central issue in church discussions to
questions of social and economic justice
if you think about the state of sort of
global economics for the last 10 years I
mean crisis after crisis sort of a
massive wave of demonstrations etc in
some way I think that wired when I would
argue is that this papacy so far has
managed to capture niche in the
political market that was not being
occupied and this is the centre-left and
people that feel completely San
franchise from the usual political
political structures IE disagree that
this is really just a matter of
rebranding I think that we clearly see
the rebranding but I think that there is
actually a very definite and very clear
change in direction of the application
and emphasis of doctrinal of doctrinal
matters on the floor on the ground
clutter keller people often tend to
seize on remarks like the one that Pope
Francis made when he was asked about
homosexuality and he said well Who am I
to judge does that mean that there's a
lot of hope riding on real doctrinal
shift in future I think there is a lot
of hope but I don't see that it will be
fulfilled this hope but why he puts the
whole person the whole human being in
the center of his of his preachings of
his writings of his
saying and he doesn't start with
counting sins and mistakes and saying
you can't do that and you should not
that but first why he uses the metaphor
the our first duty is to healing to heal
wounds and then second we can talk about
everything else when the wounds are
healed so this is a this is a real shift
the kind of change in style that we're
seeing Derek Scully how much of it the
humility the simplicity how much of it
has to do with his jesuit background I'm
not sure I think it's more to do it
where he's come from I mean this is a
man who used to go out at night into the
slums I mean this is the contradiction
the frustration people had in the past
yr priest telling me and my problematic
marriage but marriage why is a priest
with Prada handmade slippers telling me
about poverty and so this is a man who
comes with it with a different
credibility so I don't think I mean he's
gone through trans transformations in
his jesuit background and there were
some questions asked we were asking
questions a year ago did he perhaps
betray some of his brothers in south
america but he he seems has made a shift
from a jesuit or to a bishop of the poor
and that seems to made the transition
now to a pope who talks about global
issues global poverty global challenges
that seems to be more credible and
dancing through what people are
enthusiastic to hear well Jesuits have
been I mean the ministry of the poor so
in a sense I think that you know
uncommon excellent communicators for you
know many many many years so I think
that in a sense it fits this kind of
image and profile now I would like to
stress what you said why he doesn't make
theological abstract abstractions but
what he says is really full of life and
full of experience by anyone who's been
to a judge dredd education would think
it's not who you exist in your mind and
you are a good an intellectual argument
are you go to get your hands dirty and I
think these people have a feeling this
Pope is actually somebody who kisses
feat of of poor people this is somebody
who embraces the sick and you see these
images he's not afraid of getting in
touch of getting in touch and US has
tremendous effect particular in this
media age so that's the the change in
approach and style let's take a look at
changes or potential changes in theology
and doctrine if there are any here's a
report Francis has opened up the church
appointing Cardinals from beyond the
borders of Europe including from some of
the world's poorest countries Haiti
Nicaragua and Burkina Faso he's issued
blistering critiques of capitalism
speaking of an idolatry of money a kiss
huh the church all of us must strip off
our worldly wealth that leads to vanity
pride and idolatry in the portal of an
entire of would hook a little at thee as
regards the church the Pope has
appointed a team to revamp the Vatican
Bank which has been accused of money
laundering and has promised more
transparency but despite reforms Francis
holds tight to traditional values on
matters such as contraception abortion
and divorce he may be as conservative as
his predecessor Benedict the 16th is the
church undergoing a sea change or is it
just a change of style
Martin kaku both liberals and
conservatives like to try to claim Pope
Francis as one of their own I took a
look at his Wikipedia page preparing for
this discussion it's definitely been
written by the conservatives what do you
think where does the truth lie I think
this is actually just a difficult figure
to read I mean and of course the
question here depends on what you mean
by liberals what you mean by
conservatives it's very clear that the
type of conservatism that we would see
in the US and it is sort of neoliberal
conservatism most certainly will not
look at this man as an ally it's a
matter of fact I mean you know most of
the very critical voices have come out
of those waters on the other hand I mean
you have all this kind of left-wing
liberals or progressives of a certain
brand feminists among them and you know
libertarians and and anarchists that
really just think that nothing is
nothing news happening here that this
just a rehashing as a steric put it with
it with a new brand so what we have is a
repackaging of old and really quite ugly
traditions I think that both of those
perceptions are wrong I mean I think
that in a sense we do have a return to a
certain form of gospel and evangelism
that is very much at the center of the
doctrinal position so I don't really
think that you know conservatives have a
leg to stand on to be honest in the
criticism of for instance economic
positions but on the other hand truth be
told is that I do not believe that here
we will see a massive change in terms of
doctrine in terms of content these
things this is not a democracy this is
still a doctrinal this still a doctrinal
sister dark Scully if there is a certain
ambiguity here is that because Pope
Francis intentionally cultivates it well
I think so I mean he knows he has a role
to fulfill and that role is not to
contradict his predecessor so you can't
you cannot just walk in and say oh by
the way the previous guy forget
everything he said I've got some new
ideas here I've got I've got something
here in my pocket he can't do that all
he could the best we can hope with this
man is that he can change the structures
changed thinking change open a few
windows legends in there and then he's
he's a 77-year old man with one lung
and he's not going to be around forever
but he can perhaps by not coming out as
explicitly doctrinal on certain issues
he has created a freedom of movement a
wriggle room for his his successor and I
think that's where we need to think
about Pope's do not contradict their
predecessor I'm sorry can I say I think
that there is a problem though in the
way that we're considering not only
Vatican politics but politics in general
when you hear the criticism that this
are not substantive changes in the mind
of people politics is something that
sort of you do and then once you're done
it is done and then you have the reform
of the church how is it reform by
reforming it the fact is that I think
that this picture which is a progressive
brought a process by which you change
cultures in which other voices have more
space in which the systems of
conversation changed that is actually
the reform and I think that's something
that perhaps also to answer your
previous question we're actually seeing
let's come back to that in a moment but
maybe just take a look at some of the
issues that were mentioned in our report
starting with economics and politics
Claudia Keller certainly this is not the
first time that a pope where the church
has criticized capitalism does Pope
Francis really take that critique
further while he has a very clear point
of view saying this iconic economy kills
and he doesn't care about analysis and
interpretations this is here where I
stand and this economy kills I guess
well Benedict in his intellectual way of
talking would not have gone that far
maybe wanting to say the same but he
couldn't he didn't find this clear and
and this clear language but I would like
to stress another point looking at the
people who who are divorced and want to
and got remarried he calls in the Senate
at the end of the year and while he is
at least open for debates and to change
doctrine in this intersection all I'm
saying are you convinced of that there
are certain voices out there saying yes
he is supporting a culture of debate but
in the end things won't change and of
course the
point that that is many people hope will
change is that divorced Catholics would
be admitted to communicate has not been
the case until the changes and the
Catholic Church don't go like that till
yesterday it was we did it this way and
from now on we do it in a totally
different way but finding ways to keep
the old model and still finding
exceptions and looking at the individual
person and and their needs and this is
how doctrine's are changed not from one
moment to the other moments positions to
change yes it's not simply one yeah the
other hand if i look at the Pope's
interview with the italian newspaper
Corriere della Sera which he just
recently gave derek Scully I'd have to
conclude I don't see that much
willingness to change on some of these
critical points on contraception for
example he reaffirmed the ban on that
the encyclical also he reiterated the
official line that marriage is a union
between a man and a woman so how much
can we really expect in this area of
family and sexuality I have never been
and would never be particularly
optimistic that there's going to be a
revolution we had a revolution a year
ago when the first pope in 600 years
stood down but we I said last year I
said this year and I would probably say
in a year's time yeah the honeymoon
period I mean the media have a huge role
to play in this you know what do you do
you create expectations you build
somebody up and then after year you get
bored and you start hacking away at them
so and I think the second year will be
far more interesting than the first year
and what do people do when they get used
to the style and when they want to see
the substance I really don't really see
anything there but perhaps there is a
huge then perhaps he's decided there is
a mass of people in who could be one
back to the church by just a slightly
different style and but people people do
not really look terribly closely they
look at doctrine how it affects them but
people are already in the church as you
soften the recent survey ninety percent
of German said they don't really agree
with Church teaching on contraception
but these are people who are going to
the church filling in the form and going
home I mean the Contras
diction couldn't be greater so and
whether or not there will be doctrinal
change questionable whether or not it
will bother people were going to church
anyway also questionable Marty Doug how
satisfied with were you with what the
Pope had to say about the sexual abuse
scandal in some ways it sounded and
indeed the media were critical in this
instance as if he was once again being
an apologist for the church saying hey
look we're the only public institution
that actually has really come out and
tried to work on this and perhaps not
going terribly far in terms of an
official apology or or soul searching
well I personally was thoroughly
satisfied I mean but it's not completely
satisfied and I'd been completely
satisfied with the church for the last
like 12 years of this story I mean or
the last six years in which we actually
have had full accounts not only this I
mean the question of the relation with
justice and jurisdictions national
jurisdictions and so on was atrocious
that response in the UN was atrocious it
should have never happened one would
have expected that with a better PR
project they would have done much better
I think the difference between questions
such as say sexual minorities and things
like the sexual abuse scandal in this
sense I mean I beg to disagree with
Derek I think that the point is that
insofar as the Pope and the church is
not actually pushing that the ama phobic
agenda then and we hear less of that in
the parishes and we hear less of that on
the ground I mean in churches in Latin
America or in churches in pollen and the
Ukraine or in charges in in the
Philippines then the space opens for a
sea change it might be very you know
very gradual it might not represent a
revolution but I think that we actually
will see something that maybe it's not
doctrinal but it's still a change when
we're talking about things like sexual
abuse we actually think should expect
and demand as citizens of juridical
orders that in fact justice be justice
be served and the problem that we have
here is that this is not only a matter
of political changes in the structure
and practice of the church that is fine
we actually have a story of a cover-up
cover up that probably has lasted for
the better part of the 20th century if
not before this demands that Jude
occasion of justice this demands justice
this is not a matter of political
options and in this sense if the Vatican
can not do it themselves it is very
clear in my mind that European powers
and national powers have the duty to the
man and push the church Claudia Keller
were you also disappointed with what the
Pope had to say on sexual abuse yeah you
mentioned this interview by Corriere
della Sera and I found it quite
depressing what he said there that the
most abuses happen in families and that
we are the only institution that are
continually attacked I mean yes he's
right but it really sounds like we're we
are the poor church and please leave us
alone and I think here what accounts for
the discrepancy between how he speaks to
that subject and the openness that he's
shown on other issues I don't know I
don't know I don't think you can
underestimate the defensive pneus I mean
I'm coming from Ireland a sexual abuse
scandal there's been running for 20
years that has literally undermined the
foundation of the church and at some
point and people in the church stopped
listening and they started getting very
very defensive and I think that probably
has permeated right up to the Vatican
they feel that they kind of get a fair
hearing doesn't really matter what you
do i think what do you say yeah it's a
bit it's a rather unfortunate to say
what actually most abused takes place in
the family like water it look over there
you know and but he we have not got a
way of discussing child I think child
abuse is the issue and Charlie's in the
church abuse of trust in people were
supposed to be immoral and morally ours
are role models for us is terrible but
there isn't a debate about child abuse
is childish the problem i don't think
the child care who's abusing them if and
i think that's the point he was trying
to make their we need to have a
discussion my child degrees and we can
also discuss the church and the church
husband addressing this and they aren't
just now so defensive i don't think you
can actually have a sensible discussion
protecting out with the media i don't
think that i think the feeling is just
that this is just too much too much too
much hurt in this debate
we shouldn't forget about the candidate
conservative powers that are still there
in the Vatican like for example Gans
wine or the chief of the face
congregation Miller who always thought
oh the whole discussion on child abuse
is just a media campaign and while he
has 22 proly balance out the powers
there but sorry but I think that there
is also an interesting caveat to be made
that offense a matter of fact there is
still a civil war going on inside the
Vatican and there are very strong
reasons to believe that in fact there
are this is actually an excellent
opportunity for the people around France
is to organize a purge I don't think
that a purge could actually happen
overnight I think that certainly the
statement to the Coriolis etta was like
yeah of course I bit my wife but the guy
upstairs killed her so this is obviously
not a defense you judge different crimes
but then let's talk about the power
structures in the church but let me
start with a point that is perhaps the
bridge between sex and family issues and
those power structures namely the role
of women here to the Pope has indicated
that he wants to see things change and
yet on the other hand he said ordination
no women are not going to be ordained so
what do you think Claudia Keller where
are we going on the role of women and
would it make a difference to the church
what I found it very and beak what in
what he said about it was a big year is
about women you're right and if if you
if he if this is really was him what he
wants to to empower the feminine in in
the Vatican he should he should call
women into into offices into into
Vatican ministries at least while they
are there are Catholic women who who
from from the rides from from the
clerical right would be would be allowed
to do that and I definitely want to him
to go further there would either of the
gentleman on our panel object to such a
change no I don't think so but I think
that we have this contradiction that the
more you talk about an issue the less
likely or probably
to see change if not by him by by his
successor this is the bizarre attitude
of the papacy that the more people are
buying a little bit something I find it
quite positive that he has decided that
homosexuality is not the world biggest
problem poverty is and the fight against
hiv/aids is and I think most people
welcomed on the less you talk about
homosexuality the more rigor room I
think you create later on perhaps the
less to his discussion so there is a
contradiction air you want have a debate
about the role of women but the more
it's discussed the more the spotlight is
on it I think the less he the more he is
under scrutiny from conservatives and so
on it seems as if you are all suggesting
that the Pope has made one very
significant change in the way that the
church functions namely to encourage a
multiplicity of viewpoints to encourage
more debate one thing he's done on the
issue of sex and family issues is to
send out a questionnaire asking what lay
people think about the church's
attitudes on these issues that's quite
an interesting new approach mounting gak
how far will it take us I think it will
take us actually very far again I mean I
tend to read politics in a slightly
different way I think that the story
here is not about what headlines we
produce the stories what happens on the
ground and what kind of performances are
allowed in the context of the church you
know whether women become priests or not
I mean I think that this to be perfectly
honest is an absolutely irrelevant
question the sense is that this is an
institution that has its limits now when
you actually go out and sort of try to
bring Maya T and try to being bring
Bishop breeze into structures of power
and you're clearly showing that this is
going to oppose Cardinals and Korea etc
etc you're actually setting the grounds
for a very different type of performance
so I sort of invite to think of I would
invite you all to think of sort of the
Vatican the Vatican political system or
any other for that matter as a
performance in a sense the question here
is how is it that this groups are going
to start interacting with with others if
the bait shops really take central stage
or take more of the central stage the
balance of power will change and that
means that the way in which
adjudications and in something on the
ground get done will actually refer to
he apparently does want to give power
more power to the bishops there are to
be to decision-making sign odds of
bishops Claudia Keller this year and
next they will be taking up sex and
family issues that questionnaire I
mentioned will be presented to them how
do you see that changing the way that
the church works and potentially also
doctrine if at all well I think this is
really quite interest in giving more
power to the National Bishop conferences
but the National Bishop conferences then
have to take over take this power be
courage enough to take this power and I
I think this will take a while there is
a new bishop at the head of the German
Church now he has just been elected you
were covering that change what will that
mean why he he is he's in the group of
the eighth in the Vatican who advises
Pope Francis and he has a very good
standing in the Vatican and he's a very
powerful man here in a German Church and
I think he is the right man to give
Church here in Germany and you standing
and in you yeah being heard in in in in
society so he's right it's not it's not
about giving away power it's what the
people who get the power do with it and
I think you'll need to watch for two
things I mean what what Pope Francis
doing is he's in one case there have
been sentence in the past but they've
met in private and the Pope was written
a report and people can question the
validity of the exercise in other cases
there have been structures that were
created by Vatican to that have never
been invoked so if the Pope sort of
opens the possibilities of handing over
power to institutions that existed only
on paper but were never invoked or where
he had the last word and that is
interesting on the one hand and on the
other hand it's what these people
actually do wednesday have the rain
and I would be very curious about then
what will happen because we see in let's
say in the the Church of in the Anglican
Church what happens when you sort of
open things up you can have very lively
discussions just try and bring it to a
conclusion and so that could be quite an
unruly discussion and you may see the
Pope actually although we didn't want to
actually trying to come in in the end
and offer can we try and come to a
consensus here so that will be
interesting not every Bishop not every
priest is happy about the new culture of
debate because it means a lot of
insecurities martin garrix certainly
people who aren't happy would be members
of the Curia the group of eight which
Claudia Keller just mentioned which also
includes the German Bishop Bishop mr.
marks that group has been created by him
from five different continents to
basically look at how to reform the
Curia and it is a very very
controversial job indeed what do you
think can they do it well I mean can
they actually change an entire
institutional culture I again my answer
is dependent it all depends what you
mean by change can there be a
progressive a gradual change of culture
which actually ultimately results in the
change of the way in which the Vatican
performs yeah of course that can happen
now can somebody come in sit down and
say well let's just move the boxes
around and then everything will work
fine the denser of course it's not that
you can oh oh they're doing they have
after all already made some very
significant alterations to the Vatican
Bank which had been a source of so much
corruption yes but the problem that we
still have within the the vatican bank
is that the vatican bank still has
internal structure so what you have now
is much stronger oversight the question
is whether that oversight translates
into practices I you know what what we
do see is that there is a difference
from the top-down and bottom-up ways of
change I think that what we have seen
with the entry of Francis into the
papacy is a very strong commitment to
the idea that you can do some things
bottom up the problem is whether you can
do things bottom up in something that is
as recalcitrant as a bureaucracy of the
size of the bureaucrats in the Vatican I
think it's quite true and Dave I we
could see in the next year they'll do a
bit like Star Wars the Curia fights back
and with if that actually happens but I
was speaking to a very high ranking
Irish religious recently he said the
Curie can do what they want now but what
what Pope Francis done is quite simple
he has moved out of the papal palace and
by doing that the Curia are no longer
the gatekeepers to who he sees they're
no longer creating his reality this was
often the problem and the criticism with
with Pope Benedict that they were
filtering and you know they didn't even
have internet i think at some point so
and so the fact that he is in this
guessed that he decides who he sees and
they have to come and see him and he can
say no to see them so i think and when
decisions are finally being made and the
Pope is now out of a reality a curio
created reality and into another reality
so I think yes the Cure will probably be
very resistant to change but they were
Pope Francis seems to be trying to
create a post Curia reality or at least
throughout leave behind the reality they
were creating for previous popes and i
think that's it was simple he poked he
packed his bag you never even moved into
the papal palace and moved into this
guest has i think that's actually quite
significant to kind of be underestimated
claudia killer that takes us back to the
idea of diversity as a force for change
perhaps sometimes even for very
subversive change do you think the fact
that we have a much greater degree of
global input also through the g8 do you
think that makes a significant
difference here sure sure and while Pope
Benedict was said to be a person who
strongly things for in European ways of
thinking and of intellectual debate and
so with this Pope the world the world
swords in the world intellectual
debating culture comes into the Curia
and I think this is a it's a very good
very massive change yeah martin gak
this Pope as an Argentine has set out to
make the church a truly vital global
institution a big tent as it were
nonetheless there are still some very
significant disparities between
Catholics say in Europe and the US vs
Asia and Africa surveys show that in
Asia and Africa a large majority of
Catholics agree with the conservative
doctrines of the church the statistics
are nearly exactly a mirror image the
other way around if you ask Europeans
and Americans what does that mean for
the future of this big tent he's trying
to create I think if you really sort of
are committed to the idea if you're
committed to the idea that the church is
a global organization and I certainly am
I think that you need to bear in mind
that the segmentation of its public will
be actually extremely extremely broad so
your problem is not only that you have
so for instance there will say only we
see on study from a couple of days ago I
think we're a couple of weeks ago
showing that seventy-five percent of
people in Asia and Africa think that
couples who live together better not
married live in sin whereas in Europe
and the US it's actually exactly the
other way around seventy-five percent
special Europe think that this is
actually fine the problem though is that
the people that are saying this kind of
stuff for instance in the US are most
likely people that have economic
commitments economic policy commitments
that align better to the right whereas
the conservatives in social issues in
Africa or in Asia especially in very
poor communities are people that very
likely in economic policy issues will
align to the left the interesting thing
about this if you think about sort of
the global map is that you really have a
complete complete this aggregation of
political alignment the beauty of this
is that or the beauty of this political
project in the Vatican now is that there
seems to be a capacity to read political
priorities and it seems to me that the
political priority that has been
identified is the lack of a center-left
political agenda so people seem to be
willing to say you know what we've been
talking about my sexuality abortion etc
etc but I cannot fit my
children but we're going out to the
streets of Madrid but we're going out
the streets of Venezuela but we're going
out and straight self just look anywhere
and you will find something so i think
that the foresight here has really been
about identifying political priorities
if i understand all of you correctly
this culture of debate this idea of a
multiplicity of viewpoints at least
tolerating it so to speak is to be
combined with what the Pope has called a
culture of mercy meaning an acceptance
of the fact that people may not live by
the doctrines that the Catholic Church
professes and nonetheless are welcome in
the big tent my Derek Scully would that
go far enough to keep Europeans and
Americans on board in a church that
doesn't change doctrinally no I i I'm
quite pessimistic on that front I think
eventually he's going to be I mean it's
a due to to give an interview to Italian
newspaper is one thing and to actually
put a doctrinal teaching is something
else and I think eventually and the not
the mask will fall that sounds like
there's something sinister behind that
but eventually you'll be forced he will
be nailed down he'll be forced to nail
himself down doctrinally and and that I
think is where the honeymoon will end
people would say oh maybe it was just a
media thing after all he's a lovely man
unfortunately he's on a ship going in
the direction and I don't want to get on
board that ship so can I ask him in the
following question I mean to me I run a
secular I run around at the radical
secular so I am i clearly come from the
camp that it's not particularly
committed to doctrinal positions the big
tent religiously might be interesting
and it might be an interesting question
as to the France effect brings more
people into the church makes more people
more religious all that is interesting
enough the question that to me is much
more relevant is whether we do not
actually are directly in front of the
first build up of a massive political
tent forget the question of religion I
will never be a member of the church I
have already you know I have already
given up on my rabbi I will not be a
member of the church but as an atheist I
remain committed to the idea that I can
overlap Paul
ethical consensus with things that this
man is saying irrespective of what the
religious position is so I don't need
his doctrinal change what I need to see
is what happens politically and I
actually have the impression church need
a revitalization of faith in a very
different sphere quite apart from
politics in order to remain a living
organism in the world of the 21st
century my answer to that would be no no
I don't think it does I think that what
it actually I think that there is sort
of an over commitment or ideas of
religiosity I think that when you have
people that are in a state of crisis you
need something of this kind when you
have communities and countries which
have more stable positions there is a
very different need I would have to
disagree martyr I mean I was a
politician and Bishop comes in and
starts wagging his finger at me I would
say to why don't you sort out your own
mess before you come in here lecturing
me and the church is in in particular in
Europe is in a feeble position or it's
in a position of retrenchment and I
although I agreed that the Pope is
perhaps the first globalized Pope
touching on globalized issues that are
affecting a global audience and I don't
think the church is in a position at the
moment it the engine is the lid is open
on the hub and he is tinkering with the
engine unless that engine isn't working
again and the church becomes relevant
you cannot go in and start influencing
political shaking your head is it I
would say well that that Pope Francis
has this this aura and this power is
because he's the head of this church of
this world church and if this church is
not able to to revitalize its face then
it will shrink and shrink and shrink and
somebody like the Pope won't have this
power anymore in future honestly think
that I just wouldn't yeah but would not
be well then he couldn't speak that
powerfully yes sir in his political
agenda either so I actually wonder I
mean if we should really be persuaded by
the idea that people are going to church
precisely because they are committed to
doctrinal or theological position as a
matter of fact I would tell you that
most of the people that I know that
going to churches have absolutely no
idea about crystallogr Trinitarian
theology and I would argue that these
are actually central everything for
political
Oh positions there are they looking for
something else that's intuitive that's
emotional that we often put under the
name faith I would not I would I mean I
would not say that when we talk about
politics were merely talking about party
politics when you have certain certain
proclivities when you see somebody who's
poor somebody who is suffering this is
actually a political commitment it's a
form of apology should be going after
the floating voters it's not what you're
saying people know and he should go I'm
saying that he has already gone and in
many many countries around the world he
has already captured them so no it's not
that this is something that he should do
this is something that has already been
happening under a nose for the last year
and I think that we see it in many many
definition of floating voters is you
never captured and we only rent them for
a little while and then they turn
against you but we shouldn't forget the
fundament why he's doing all that why
he's preaching in the way he's preaching
that is God and that is his faith all
right yeah Claudia Keller where we
certainly have seen an immense
enthusiasm and expansion of the catholic
church that is in Africa and Asia could
you imagine that in say fifty or a
hundred years Catholicism might be
largely a religion of those parts of the
world um well it yeah yes I could
imagine I mean in Africa and in in in
Africa isn't it already the the most
powerful religion Catholicism I think so
i believe it is yes yeah as well along
with the Evangelical Protestant
movements yes could you imagine that
Catholicism more or less disappears from
Europe radical secularists this is a
society that's often referred to as
post-christian no I don't think that it
will completely disappear no there is to
search in human beings for trance
transcendence for phrase for something
that is higher than just ordinary
ordinary ordinary life and I don't think
that this will disappear I actually
would argue that if in Africa and in
Asia and the countries where you
actually have really strong president of
Catholicism there is actually serious
development in matters of Health and
technol
over the last 20 years we will see
actually a twinkling of Christianity and
religion journal I don't think it will
ever be complete look at the US and look
at a country like Ireland Derek Scully
it saw a massive exodus from the
Catholic Church after the abuse scandal
where do you think Catholicism is going
in your country well I if you ask me 20
years ago today and in 20 years time 20
years or older said it is in the DNA it
cannot be extracted now I look at it and
it's going to be so it's going to be
empty in 20 years time so it will
dwindle and will die it will just
retreat to perhaps the size it should
always have had in the past and that
despite the enthusiasm for a pope
francis indeed i think let's talk in a
year's time and see how much enthusiasm
is left yeah we may well do that thank
you so much for being with us today and
thanks to all of you out there for
tuning in see you soon